I told you earlier this week about the
growing war on the media that Donald
Trump is waging and it's getting worse
and sadly I don't know if the press
corps is totally ready to fight against
it they're speaking up but what will
they actually do here's what happened
the White House banned CNN journalist
Caitlin Collins from attending a rose
garden event yesterday at the White
House she was called into the White
House and badgered and scolded for
so-called inappropriate questions that
she asked Trump during an oval office
event or earlier yesterday who was one
of the officials who read Caitlin
Collins the riot act it was Bill Cheyne
formerly of Fox News Now of the White
House as well as press secretary
Sarah Huckabee Sanders well these must
have been wildly inappropriate questions
right not really one of them was did
Michael Cohen betray you something
Caitlyn Collins asked President Trump
yesterday really inappropriate right mr.
president are you worried about what
Michael Cohen will say to prosecutors
whoa we got to get her out right away we
have the video these are Caitlin
Collins's inappropriate questions and
her supposedly inappropriate behavior at
the White House yesterday
[Music]
Thank You mr. president Michael Cohen is
going are you worried about what is on
the other tapes thank you thank you very
much
thanks everybody
this really is not a big deal I mean
there's a lot of screaming and pushing
and whatever it always goes this way and
the idea that this was just so offensive
been inappropriate that Katelyn Collins
deserved to be banned is crazy so I've
got good news and bad news the good news
here is that most media outlets even Fox
News are defending Katelyn Collins and
Fox News put out a statement saying
quote we stand in strong solidarity with
CNN for the right to full access for our
journalists as part of a free and
unfettered press the White House
Correspondents Association also put out
a statement saying that this was wholly
inappropriate not Katelyn Collins
behavior but kicking her out of a
subsequent event because of that she
asked because she asked these questions
the White House Correspondents
Association said it was wholly
inappropriate wrongheaded and weak this
is the creeping authoritarianism that
I've been warning about for a year and a
half now and Trump recently said at a
rally what you're seeing and what you're
reading is not what's happening
basically saying you cannot believe even
the most basic facts being reported by
the media authoritarian dictatorships
and fascist regimes tell the citizens
citizenry literally do not believe what
you see in the news they ban media they
don't like from covering them and these
aren't tactics that start to shade in
the direction of authoritarianism
they're straight out of that playbook
period and there's another fact that
makes this even worse which is that
Katelyn Collins wasn't in the Oval
Office merely as a CNN reporter in the
video I played for you she was there as
a reporter representing the press pool
which sometimes happens one reporter is
designated as representing the press
pool at a particular event
so without Caitlyn's questions there
were no questions period which is
exactly what the White House wants the
narrative can't be questioned and that's
what the Trump administration wants and
if your view is David listen cNN has
been unfair to Trump and they sort of
deserve this CNN was the only press
representation at that Oval Office event
because Caitlin Collins was the press
pool reporter so when CNN was singled
out as being inappropriate they were
representing the press at law
during that event and it's sort of like
kicking out the media period now legally
there are questions this was a
credentialed White House reporter if you
ban a credentialed reporter from an open
press event the later event at the Rose
Garden because you didn't like her
questions she didn't commit a crime
she doesn't leak classified information
she didn't do anything she didn't break
into the Oval Office you just didn't
like the questions that might be a
violation of the First Amendment and as
usual there will never be repercussions
for it and it will be the statement that
some ethics lawyer tells us in a week
and then of course it'll be forgotten
because there will be ten more scandals
by then but there is that legal question
and when you look at Fox News saying the
White House crossed the line with CNN
you know how backward things have gotten
and this is because and what we're very
critical of Fox News on the opinion side
all the time Pat it's completely whacked
out in the tank for Trump on the opinion
side there are actually proper standard
traditional journalists that work for
Fox News who recognize the danger of
this usually the reviews are overridden
by the opinion side of Fox News I'm not
defending Fox News as an entity but
there are just normal journalists at Fox
News who see this for what it is
yeah we talked about like Shep Smith and
Bret Baier but they're also those
journalists who you never really hear
about exactly you know there we see an
instance of integrity here from Fox News
and that's pretty rare it's horrible
that the opinion and bias permeates the
news site at Fox News but the actual
reporters and I'm actually in touch with
a couple of them there's a couple of Fox
News just baseline reporters regular
field reporters who pay attention to the
David Pakman show might be shocking to
some of you they do put their personal
politics aside they just understand the
basics of journalistic integrity which
have been violated here and it often
doesn't come through on the Fox News
Channel but real journalists recognize
how this is extraordinarily dangerous
and this is a danger that we all need to
be fighting against it's creeping we
know Trump wants it he's talked about
journalism licenses he's talked about
trying to pull certain publications out
of print or off air it's really scary
stuff and we're seeing a little bit of
the press corps banding together so Fox
News put out a statement we saw a couple
of examples of when Sarah Huckabee's
Sanders didn't answer a question from
one reporter the next reporter called on
said can you ask the same question or
said can you answer that question so
we're seeing a little bit of it but the
degree to which this anti media crusade
is building should freak everybody out
whether you're a progressive leftist or
a constitutional right or whatever this
is a red alert
and we also have to be worried about
self-censorship too because if you know
that you if you ask a tough question
they'll cut your access turns out in the
next press conference you may ask
something that's not so pressing yes
there's no question about it and that is
it's sort of like on YouTube where
listen you can put up any video you want
but depending on what you put up it
might not have ads run and therefore you
won't make any money strictly speaking
you're not banned from putting up
whatever video you want but you may
start to self-censor in order to have
your videos monetized similar sort of
dynamic send me your thoughts and
specifically my question for you is if
you believe I am over blowing this press
war against the press write in and tell
me why I'm on Twitter at D Pakman and
the show is on Twitter at David Pakman
show